♪ Let's go ♪
这边没有
我当年来的时候冷的坐在我后面的
你看松鼠就在那边爬上爬下
哎
奇经做了整个小屋
不怕换礼物到嗨
嗨哈哈哈
他一直跟我玩躲猫猫都聊到哪去
♪ 我不是故意注意 ♪
是不想吃
康是真的蛮好吃的
♪ 不小心抬头看见诶 ♪
这个草莓真的很像鼻头粉刺
诶鼻头粉刺
你看他真的好秃哦
雷克啊
♪ 你看在男孩肩上露出甜蜜的微笑 ♪
♪ 给你爱爱爱 ♪
今天非常的lucky
这个温度
♪ 爱爱咿呀咿爱爱爱爱爱爱呀咿呀 ♪
♪ 就是这摩天大爱 ♪
感觉感觉那边蛮热闹的诶
好少女屁股屁股屁股快点
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
♪ Oh i'm ready ♪
♪ One two ♪
♪ Ready go ♪
♪ One two ready go ♪
♪ 大笑一笑 ♪
♪ 什么大不了 ♪
这个动起来的话算鲜艳的
最上面的这个蓝色是天青池
现在在五大湖畔
当时天津池都是跟金子同价的
所以在文艺复兴时期
巴洛克时期想成为画家不容易
你要有大量的资金才能成为画家
那我付完才知道他现在这个圣旨是人的比例
不是孩子的比例
以前有一些画风真的是会这样
就是baby
但是他是会用人的比例去画它
然后淡彩画蛋是鸡蛋的蛋
彩色的彩蛋
彩蛋彩画
其实大部分都我们会觉得那个颜色扑扑的
他刚刚说这个蓝色是很贵很蓝
我觉得可能也是因为这样
所以它的颜色才相较还可以涂的比较鲜艳
♪ 雨下再大又怎样 ♪
相对来说感觉我好像比较认识的是油画
我是觉得还挺喜欢的
我比较更懂得去欣赏油画的
20年前来的时候
那时候是因为我工作非常非常忙碌
就是第一张专辑之后拍西街少年
西街少年之后发爱你爱你完拍听过嘉一
听过佳怡晚安honey
接着马上就拍微笑pasta
而且这些东西你拍摄需要时间
录音需要时间
所以是被填的满满满满满满
难到不知道怎么去消化自己
没有时间好好看看
真感受身边的人事物
所以那时候我就告了一个月的假
选择了来纽约
然后上个半天课的那种言学校来游学
♪ 见面时候该说些什 ♪
那段时间纽约给了我很多
也让我慢慢找回了很久没有过的
自在呼吸的感觉
20年后
我带着SUGHAI2.0
带着音乐
也带着更完整的自己
重回到了这座城市
♪ 正在清醒的记忆都会暂停 ♪
见到你时
我要说什么
这一次来到这
哎
从来没有在这边看过秀
结果没有在那边看过秀
要自己在那边演秀
对你好威
就算着追着我全部变得鲜
看结束发财的人能明白地球和我都太冲动动
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你不只一天多一点 ♪
让我心甘情愿爱你心灵和SUGLAND
全体成员很感谢你们带来精彩舞台
感谢你们为我们带来的快乐
向上的力量和美好的回忆哟
希望这样的快乐和向上的力量
也永远陪伴着你们
陪伴你
我一起成为更好的自己
我永远期待我们的再次相见
辛苦啦
谢谢比心
♪ 你很想笑 ♪
♪ 我失去你那一秒 ♪
♪ 心突然就变老 ♪
♪ See you went away ♪
♪ 喧闹的街 ♪
♪ 没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角 ♪
♪ 永远sugar hsi ♪
♪ Super high ♪
享受快yes
太棒了
今天就是在纽约有一个完美的ending
完美的结束
有一点荣幸也可以拿来小小骄傲的地方
是是呃
Madison square garden
首位华人女歌手在这里开唱
嗯嗯觉得我们很棒
然后我感觉就是这两场的观众都玩的很尽兴
这样刚才也有观众朋友做的那个牌子
就是在跟SUGHAI的所有的伙伴们说谢谢
因为常常我们都跟他们说谢谢
他说要跟我们说谢谢
很感谢我们带给他们这种快乐跟正向的力量
我觉得就是这样子的双向奔赴是最美丽的
然后是现场的这种最吸引人的地方还是方向
♪ 我在你身旁啊啊我在你身旁 ♪